[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce set 8 sport après une
période particulièrement délicate pour
le sport local avec le coronavirus nous
ferons un point dans ce magazine sur le
monde sportif dans le département
sommaire comme vous le savez tous les
championnats locaux ont été fortement
perturbée à cause de la pandémie du
comique 19
tous les classements des principaux
clubs du département sont à retrouver
dans quelques instants dans ce set 8
sport après le déconfinement plusieurs
sports sont autorisés à la pratique
comme le tennis le golf ou encore le
cyclisme et la course à pied
coup de projecteur en ce magazine enfin
un zoom sur l'agenda sportif yves binois
dans les prochains mois un planning
totalement chamboulé avec la crise
sanitaire annulation notamment de l'open
de france de golf et du paris versailles
[Musique]
avec le corolla virus la fin de saison
sportive a été fortement perturbée dans
le département des yvelines des
classements avec des montées et des
descentes ont tout de même été établies
par les instances dans l'urgence léa
détails avec l'épidémie de kovy de 19
les compétitions ne sont pas allées à
leur terme et un classement définitif a
été établi en football versailles montre
à l'année prochaine en nationale 2 en
terminant premier devant ivry de son
côté trappe termine avant dernier mais
se maintient tout de même en régionale 2
seul une formation l'équipe 2 de
versailles descendra dans la poule suite
aux décisions des instances on est
content qu'on était mal parti en début
de saison
et puis voir même à l'arrêt du
championnat on était comme l an dernier
bon il nous restait encore quand même
cette nuit rencontre donc on est des
possibilités de se maintenir mais bon à
l'issue de cette réunion
oui c'est sûr qu'on est super content et
on va pouvoir maintenant se consacrer à
une saison prochaine il a préparé au
mieux dans le championnat de première
division de district ces mots repas qui
monterait à l'année prochaine en
régionale 3 en terminant premier devant
à des cours une montée historique pour
le club
personne n'a crié au scandale le zew
c'était tout à fait normal quand on
était promue en première place et en
rugby en fédérale 2 depuis trois ans
plaisir restera une année de plus dans
cette division
à la lutte pour le maintien les plaisirs
aux à terme finalement 9e sur 12 du
championnat en disputant 17 journées la
frustration pas avoir pu gagner
notre maintien d'une manière sportive la
frustration également de ne pas voir
si on a été capable d'aller chercher
cette qualification parce qu'on était
encore dans dans la course à la 6e place
qualificative
donc voilà que c'est très frustré on
était sur une très belle dynamique de
phase retour
une division en dessous en fédérale 3
verseille en course pour une éventuelle
montée en fin de saison a vu sa saison
s'achever prématurément comme toutes les
autres équipes
le rcv promu cette saison termine donc
quatrième une bonne image de la réussite
sportive de cette saison puisque un
promu aura bataillé avec avec les
premières équipes pour les places
qualificatives du championnat de france
des gal une patte qualifications mais
cela veut dire que le 8 le versailles
aura bien signé son arrivée et sa
remontée en fédérale 3 toujours en rugby
l'union rugby centre 60,18 né d'une
fusion entre le sky rugby montigny le
bretonneux termine 5e du championnat
honneur pour sa première année
d'existence handball plaisir ce maintien
en nationale 3 en terminant 8e de sa
poule les féminines de monti le
bretonneux ment quand elle a monté après
avoir terminé la saison à la quatrième
place
une semaine avant on était deuxième on a
perdu le dernier match qui en fait nous
nous comment dire nous laisse en fait en
nationale 2 pour la saison prochaine car
les compétitions ont été à compter du 12
mars ont été complètement interrompue et
on a comme andy repris le solde à ce
moment là donc ça a été ça a été un peu
surprenant je reste en fait optimiste
pour pour l'année à venir
en basket en nationale 3 masculine
trappe termine la saison à la troisième
place dans la même poule l'entente le
chesnay-versailles termine juste
derrière quatrième en football américain
la saison de deuxième division des
templiers d'elancourt s'est arrêté en
mars dernier le classement était figé
sans montée ni descente qui resteront
donc en deuxième division en baseball la
saison qui réduit commencé au mois
d'avril ne se jouera finalement pas les
cougars de montigny le bretonneux ne
joueront donc aucun match cette saison
vous l'avez vu précédemment les saisons
ont été raccourcis ou annulés dans
certains cas pour nous parler des
conséquences sur les clubs locaux nous
avons avec nous via écran interposé
lionel garrigues coprésident avec
jacques moreau de l'union ruby centre 78
bonjour bonjour lionel bonjour alors lui
verser 1 78 a terminé à la cinquième
place du classement de division honneur
pour la première année à d'existence du
club
votre action tout simplement pour la
première édition c'est que coville 19 on
se souviendra de l'année de la fusion ça
sur des biens le mans 2010 neuf donc
et ma première réaction par rapport aux
résultats d'intel et c'est que avec joie
que nous partageons l'idée que nous
avons vraiment réussi à respecter
l'engagement de la première saison a
demandé à ce que la grèce prenne bien
plus du joueur ça a été le cas parce que
tu soulignes terminant 5e en équipe
première et nous terminons troisièmes
l'océan
l'équipe réserve ce qui ce qui laisse à
penser que nous avons eu raison de
penser qu'il y avait deux équipes
compétitives qui pouvaient ils pouvaient
travailler pour alors dans tous les cas
donc vous terminez à 5e du classement en
division honneur
vous n'auriez pas pu monter à on est
d'accord malgré l'interruption du
championnat pense que la suite du
championnat nous auraient soit permis de
grappiller une place soit permis de
redescendre et de l'hermine et à
quatrième par exemple on était sur une
bonne dynamique mais oui effectivement
il ya une interruption de l'activité
sportive on allait aussi une m une on
avait pas mal de blessés donc ce temps
les quais pas forcément une bonne
dynamique mais en même temps après
quelques joueurs qui est essentiel à la
chine est tellement résultats alors
maintenant on va revenir à votre rôle de
co président est ce que votre portable
n'arrête pas de sonner en ce moment avec
les licenciés qui n'arrête pas de vous
appeler c'est raisonnable puisque au
bout
alors évidemment de grande impatience de
la part de nos licenciés c'était le cas
oui hier qu'il ya des annonces de la
fédération comme d'ailleurs dans
certains médias nationaux qui bien cette
année vous allez pouvoir redémarrer dans
certaines conditions d'ailleurs mais
commencent à anticiper on a fait pas mal
de communication préalable je pense que
on est plutôt grâce à des mots du
président ou des prêts sera sur notre
site ou par des les messages
d'information vers nos licenciés on a
anticipé cette ces coups de fil un promo
trop pesant et on va pouvoir bientôt
noël je pense d'ici fin mai quelques
enseignes qui vont arriver à pouvoir
donner des balles à la manière de
redémarrer votre sport ça va se faire en
plusieurs étapes selon les dispositions
que préconise la fédération française de
rugby et quelles sont les principales
interrogations à des des joueurs dans
votre club et la ville sont basiques
c'est quand est-ce qu'on peut redémarrer
et où on en a parlé un petit peu tout à
l'heure l'émission met effectivement est
ce qu'on aura droit en mêlée alors pour
l'instant effectivement les
entraînements sans nuitée à des
personnes sans contact avec d'entrée
beaucoup puis sur le physique et puis là
la réac de la réalisation d'un joueur on
va partir de cette première étape là et
puis en espérant notamment qu' on va
pouvoir revenir facilement à l'essentiel
de notre sport qui passe nécessairement
par le contact puisque donc puisque pour
le foot et donc je pense qu'il y aura
peut-être un petit retard du rugby par
rapport à d'autres sports que financier
pour pour le club et est ce que le club
est en difficulté ou pas du tout non pas
par les difficultés bien que dans les
deux mois qui viennent de passer la
claque tivement j'ai eu des petits
problèmes structurels par des murs et
depuis ils n'ont pas les du conseil
municipaux pas pu se constituer
notamment ce qui fait que j'ai des
demandes de subventions qui nous avait
en fait on
un peu tardé sont pas encore d'ailleurs
arrivé et on a vu notre trésorerie
sensiblement baissé pas de manière grave
mais une manière suffisante pour qu'on
puisse demander et d'ailleurs certaines
méric maurepas commune en cours comme
voisins bretons ne ont fait seuls les
avances en propose effectivement de nous
aider ils ont été très solidaires pareil
pour sky et toutes celles auxquelles
notre mairie qui représente et toutes
les autres institutions qu'ils
représentent
urs et 78 montigny bien entendu il faut
reprendre le plus rapidement possible
selon nous on en a besoin on en a besoin
mais je pense que ma chili à des mesures
c'est compliqué de prendre des mesures
donc chacun d'y être de bon sens le bon
sens il soit leader rien depuis
subjectif comme notion que le bon sens
chacun a son bon sens et c'est pour ça
qu'en fait au rugby mais on respecte les
arbitres en l'occurrence pour la stran
arbitres c'est la fédération au corps et
très respectueux des consignes qu'ils
seront données on est très impatient et
dans le même temps on sera respectueux
des règles qui vont nous être heureux la
dictée merci à lionel garrigues merci
pour votre intervention dans ce set 8
sport et à bientôt sur les terrains je
l'espère à on continue à parler des
conséquences du coc vide 19 sur les
clubs locaux on l'a vu précédemment dans
le sujet sur les résultats des clubs
locaux en baseball les cougars de
montigny le bretonneux ne joueront pas
leur saison 2020 à cause du coc vide 19
une décision de la fédération qui
pourrait avoir de lourdes conséquences
pour le club à montage de xavier jaglin
cette saison le stade jean marc et celle
de montigny le bretonneux va sonner
creux les coûts guerre qui devait
reprendre au printemps le joueront
finalement aucun match à cause du
coronavirus la fédération a décidé
d'annuler la saison un coup dur
financier pour les dirigeants du club
privé notamment de merchandising et de
buvette
c'est pas qu'on soit vraiment je dirais
en complet danger mais c'est
relativement inquiétant quand même c'est
une situation vraiment inattendu
les temps sont durs pour les cougars
mais on a quand même la chance d'être
soutenue toujours au niveau au niveau
département au niveau de la région au
niveau de la mairie au niveau de
l'agglomération qui n'ont pas retiré en
fait les budgets qui était allouée cette
saison blanche pourrait également avoir
un impact sur le secteur sportif les
cougars qui évolue en première division
pourrait perdre certains de leurs
meilleurs joueurs ce qui pourrait jouer
contre nous malheureusement c'est
aujourd'hui les championnats allemands
tchèques italiens sont en passe de
reprendre puisqu'ils ont des situations
moins perturbé que les nôtres il se
pourrait vraiment que on est des joueurs
qui avaient déjà été contacté cet hiver
puisque l'année dernière on a fait une
3e place en coupe d'europe mais on a des
joueurs qui avaient déjà été contactées
qui ont toujours des contacts qui
seraient susceptibles de trouver
d'autres clubs
les cougars de montigny-le-bretonneux
espère désormais rouvrir cet été pour
les stages d'animation pour des jeunes à
partir de la deuxième quinzaine de
juillet et qui premières devrait quant à
elle reprendre en 2021 en sport
automobile la pépite du karting français
à jimmy elias est encore à l'arrêt chez
legrand courtois ne pourra reprendre la
compétition avant quelques semaines en
ce moment le pilote continue tout de
même à s'entraîner sur un circuit fermé
à jouer à des jeux de simulation en
affrontant des pilotes de formule 1 il a
enregistré cette vidéo pour tv 78
bonjour je m'appelle maillage est aux
anges quand ils atteignent 47 academy
pendant deux mois de confinement mais je
ferai pas physiquement j'ai fait une
heure d'anglais tous les jours de la
semaine et j'ai beaucoup de chance de
jouer
esteban logo simulateur et il ya deux
jours j'ai fait des tests elle que
tunisiana racing pour le développement
des moteurs va exsangue aux autres
sports à l'arrêt depuis plusieurs
semaines à la boxe les clubs ne peuvent
pas reprendre dans les salles et les
combats ont tous été annulés pour
l'instant ou en tout cas un reporter
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
l'un des meilleurs clubs du secteur la
team farruggia située à elancourt
s'entraîne pour l'instant en extérieur
dans les forêts du département en
attendant le feu vert des autorités
on écoute justement l'entraîneur du club
tanguy farrugia on avait des combats
prévus on ne sait pas où cette cendre
mais ça soit des emplois du monde aux
championnats d'europe les sports de
combat vont interpréterait pas
compliquèrent pratiquer
compaq la sueur on a obligé l'arbitré au
milieu il est obligé de toucher aussi
des sportifs
même s'ils partent des gants il ya quand
même un contact voilà la sueur quand on
a un plein combat que c'est un 12e ronde
c'est la transpiration et vol non je ne
sais pas ce qu'on va voir si certains
sports ne pourrait pas reprendre avant
plusieurs semaines voire plusieurs mois
d'autres sports sont autorisés à des à
présent c'est le cas du golf du tennis
du cyclisme encore de la course à pied
un coup de projecteur
depuis le 11 mai date du déconfinement
la vie sportive reprend partiellement
ses droits dans les yvelines et golfeurs
peuvent de nouveau tapé la balle blanche
sur la vingtaine de golf du département
sur le parcours plus de banc ni de
poubelles un protocole sanitaire est
également mise en place pour les joueurs
on ne peut pas toucher le drapeau donc
on a mis en place des systèmes pour que
la balle ne retombe pas complètement
dans le trou pour que les gens puissent
enlever sans toucher le drapeau ni le
trou leurs balles de golf
il n'y a pas de râteau sur le parcours
donc dans les obstacles les bunkers ils
sont toujours en jeu mais on demande aux
gens de ratisser en fête avec leurs
pieds ou avec un club de golf pour
penser au suivant les parties de tennis
sont également autorisés seulement
simple sur les courts totalement
découvert dans les yvelines 90 clubs sur
130 structures ont rouvert mais ils sont
tous soumis à un protocole très strict
les portes restent ouvertes les bancs et
chaises sont désinfectés et les joueurs
doivent s'engager à suivre les
procédures
chaque joueur doit arriver déjà en tenue
arrivé un petit peu juste au moment de
la réservation puisque les réservations
doivent se faire en ligne exclusivement
et puis chaque jour doit arriver
également avec ses balles et ses balles
doivent être marquées par un symbole qui
le choisissent eux mêmes dans la mesure
où ensuite
un joueur doit nous de toucher avec la
main que ses propres balles en plus de
ces deux sports dans les yvelines vous
pouvez également pratiquer la course à
pied l'équitation la marche sportive de
cyclisme sur route en respectant une
distance minimum de dix mètres entre
deux personnes les amateurs de golf
peuvent jouer à mais les professionnels
devront encore attendre l'open de france
n'aura finalement pas lieu cette année
du 2 au 5 juillet au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sur le
parcours de l'albatros l'événement phare
du monde golfique français été annulé
suite à l'épidémie du courant la virus
vous vous en doutez le rendez vous n'a
pas pu être reportées à cause d'un
calendrier surchargé
on écoute la réaction du directeur
général de la fédération française de
golf à christophe muniesa
c'est un crève coeur pour la fédération
mais pour les golfeurs aussi de ne pas
pouvoir profiter de cet open national
après c'est une évidence de le dire mais
on comprend très bien que le contexte
sanitaire actuelle ne nous permettait
pas d'organiser l'épreuve dans de bonnes
conditions
terrain triste de voir deux réalités
auxquelles on est confronté et on a
envie de se projeter d'ores et déjà vers
l'édition 2021 du golfe il devait
également il y en avoir pendant les jo
de tokyo cet été mais le rendez-vous a
été à déplacer à 2021 du 23 juillet au 8
août pour être précis de sportifs
chinois pouvaient potentiellement y
participent et nous les avons avec nous
bonjour thomas barrau que bonjour victor
lévesque
[Musique]
alors vous êtes de un sportif avec des
parcours différents thomas barrau vous
faites de l'aviron vous êtes licencié au
cercle nautique de versailles vous avez
emporté la médaille de bronze lors des
derniers jo de tokyo et vous avez à 32
ans
de votre côté à victor l'évêque vous
avez 21 ans vous êtes de la boissière
école vous êtes un sportif en devenir ou
fait partie de la génération 2024 qu'est
ce que concrètement ça change pour vous
ce report on va peut-être commencer par
vous au tome à sa frange qu'il faut
continuer à s'entraîner en plus
non je blague ce n'est pas après une
marée été sèchement appels et les jeux
de tokyo
j avoue que j avais pas que je t'ai pas
encore qualifiés donc que ça change
c'est beaucoup d'incertitudes en plus
parce que même aujourd'hui on sait pas
exactement comment va se dérouler les
mois qui nous séparent encore de des
nouvelles d'être des olympiques 2020 qui
est d or en 2021 donc c'est pas mal
d'incertitudes on essaie de continuer à
s'entraîner de la même façon un peu tous
les jours même si les échéances sont
plus lointaines en aviron la seule
échéance internationale qui reste pour
cette saison ce serait les championnats
d'europe qui déroulerait début octobre
je n'utilise le conditionnel parce que
c'est encore évidemment soumis à
l'évolution de la situation en france
mais dans les autres pays aussi
donc voilà après c'est surtout une
question de motivation mais elle est
toujours présente ça que l'équipe des
jeux c'est quand même assez particulier
donc voilà on n'a pas forcément envie de
s'arrêter tout de suite surtout quand on
se dit que que la saison se présentait
plutôt bien et que on avait encore de
belles choses à faire
victoria qui on va s'intéresser à vous
maintenant vous avez donc 21 ans
est-ce que se ressent va vous permettre
peut-être de gagner en maturité
vous êtes encore très jeune oui alors
c'est une décision que voilà je pense la
plupart des sportifs s'attendait compte
tenu de la situation
effectivement moi je suis encore très
jeune j'avais au climat qualification
déjà pour pour tokyo donc on pourrait
imaginer que ça me permettent d'acquérir
encore plus d'expérience pour l'année
prochaine
mais comme a dit thomas aujourd'hui
encore beaucoup beaucoup d incertitudes
on ne sait pas quand les saisons vont
reprendre à quel point il pourra y avoir
deux compétitions à l'étranger ou non
donc il ya beaucoup de facteurs qui sont
aujourd'hui assez flou et puis la
particularité de mon sport c'est qu'on
ait deux puisqu'il ya le cavalier bien
sûr le cheval voilà j'avais un cheval
qui était en super forme qui m'appelle
lui qualifié l'année dernière cette
année ils étaient voilà prêt après a
démarré cette saison olympique
maintenant quelle sera la situation
année prochaine je peux pas le dire bien
sûr qu'on va tout faire pour être au
même niveau de forme j'espère encore
meilleur mais encore une fois ça reste
le sport à les chevaux donc voilà je
pense qu'il faut pas seulement la tête
essayé de s'entraîner dans les
meilleures conditions possibles et puis
voilà je pense qu'une des qualités des
sportifs de haut niveau c'est de savoir
s'adapter donc voilà on prend le temps
on reste positif alors vous avez 24
aventure n'a pas vu que quand vous avez
participé à vos premiers jo c'était en
2012 à londres
vous aviez terminé septième en quatre de
pointe sans barreur poids léger est ce
qu'il faut connaître la saveur des jo le
plus rapidement possible comme victor va
le faire rapidement
marc alban l'année prochaine chez c'est
vrai que c'est un bas double tranchant
on peut dire que c'est déjà un
aboutissement et que ça peut enlever une
certaine motivation à l'entraînement au
quotidien
après en général quand on a gagné a
ajouté une fois on a plutôt envie d'y
retourner donc ça peut être une bonne
motivation complémentaires si jamais il
y en a encore besoin
c'est quelque chose qui est assez
personnellement de la shoah lecteurs de
pouvoir déjà profité des jeunes 2001 et
puis ensuite d'enchaîner agir maintenant
sur 2001 quatre arrivées très idée alors
victoire est ce que vous avez parlé
victor thomas est ce que vous avez parlé
à d'autres sportives de ce report est
commencée perçu dans le monde sportif
ouais je suis étudiant encore à sciences
po paris dans une classe spécialisée
pour les sportifs de haut niveau donc
j'ai l'occasion de d'échanger avec eux
voilà très régulièrement sur le sujet
comme je disais tout à l'heure je pense
que c'était une décision à laquelle
beaucoup de sportifs s'attendait voilà
ça paraissait impossible d'imaginer que
les jeux soient maintenus en 2020
maintenant
moi je pense que je fais partie des
privilégiés étant donné que j'ai
continué à m'entraîner normalement
pendant cette période de confinement ce
n'était pas le cas de d'amis à moi moi
là qu'ils pouvaient plus tous entraînés
ou qu'il s'entraînait uniquement à la
maison je pourrais accepter aussi le cas
de thomas donc ça change beaucoup de
paris sera évidemment voilà tout le
monde était impatient de sortir de ce
confinement
tout le monde reste prudent voilà je
pense qu'ils chacun va essayer de
reprendre l'entraînement progressivement
et je vois le propre des sportifs c'est
de faire des compétitions donc voilà je
pense qu'on est tous impatiemment de
voir l'horizon des compétitions qui
arrive à nouveau justement votre
quotidien pendant confinement c'était
quoi
victor du coup moi je continue à
m'entraîner normalement ce donc voilà je
m'entraînais tous les matins dans mes
écuries à la boissière école
et puis je profitais de mai après-midi
pour avancer mais courent encore plus
que d'habitude compte tenu du fait que
on était privé de compétition et thomas
de votre côté gt ou chênaie à côté de
versailles
j'avais la chance d'avoir un peu de
place à l'extérieur une maison avec un
jardin que je me suis entraîné chez moi
en faisant
du vélo l'intérieur noir moeurs
d'appartements et accumulation tout ça
en parallèle de deux longs et
télétravail
c'était une journée à peu près normal
sauf qu'évidemment il n'y avait pas le
lot et le déplacement jusqu'aux clubs
mais sinon le rythme était pas
fondamentalement différent tu après sur
la partie du retour des autres sportifs
je pense que c'est vraiment très
personnelle parce que il y en a qui
disait qu'il était vraiment prêt que
c'était leur moment et on sait très bien
que le cléac'h internationale d'une
saison sur l'autre elles elles changent
donc donc y en a qui étaient vraiment
très très déçu que ça puisse pas se
tenir parce qu'il sentait que c'était
c'était bon pour eux après on pense que
si c'était bon pour eux cette année en
travaillant bien encore ça devrait donc
pour l'année prochaine mais il ya quand
même des gens qui n'étaient pas très
très heureux que ça soit reporté
dernière question qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter pour les prochaines
semaines et prochains mois victor que
les concours reprenne assez rapidement
parce que ça commence à faire long et et
c'est notre énergie notre moteur et puis
que voilà il n'y a pas de pépins pour la
reprise de l'entraînement des
compétitions et que on arrive à
progresser encore plus serré atteints de
formes et pour vous thomas vraiment tout
simplement sur deux pour remonter sur
l'eau sous s'est toujours pas le cas
nous on craignait une déchirure
confinement donc pour l'instant c'est
repos forcé et puis et puis voilà on
prend du plaisir à ramer que les
consignes à ce que les conditions
sanitaires se stabilise pour qu'on
puisse à nouveau refaire des stages dans
de bonnes conditions et les reprendre le
chemin de la performance quoi tout
simplement merci à tous d'être intervenu
dans cette émission on continuera
évidemment à vous suivre sur tv à 78
deux autres événements qui vont être
reportées à cause du coc vie 19 le tour
de france 2020 a été dépassé à la fin de
l'été la grande boucle sera programmée
du 29 août au 20 septembre la dernière
étape passera par les yvelines pour la
deuxième année consécutive le peloton
s'élancera de mantes la jolie en
direction des champs elysées pour 122 km
de son côté le tournoi de tennis
de roland garros sera programmé du 20
septembre au 4 octobre porte d'auteuil
de nombreux jeunes ramasseurs de balles
ivy mois seront sur l'événement des
tennismans du département pourrait
également être présent comme florian la
cat ou arthur avril date n'est hameau de
voile à présent le départ du vendée
globe 2020 est programmé le 8 novembre
2020 depuis les sables d'olonne en
vendée sur ce tour du monde en solitaire
on devrait retrouver à louis burton le
skipper originaire de rambouillet le
sportif de 34 ans participera à son
troisième vendée globe il avait terminé
7e de la dernière édition
louis burton nous a justement envoyer
une petite vidéo on est en train de
finaliser la préparation de bureaux
râler et la mise à l'eau on va attaquer
normalement la qualification de 2000
milles au mois de juin afin d'être prêt
pour s'entraîner sur la performance au
mois de juillet au mois d'août au mois
de septembre
l'idée étant d'arriver sur ce vendée
globe
donc avec un très bon bateau préparé par
une équipe performante et avec un
objectif de faire mieux que la dernière
fois en 2016-2017 où j'avais pu terminer
7e de la course sur le précédent durval
et donc ben un top 7
et idéalement un top 5 et voilà et merci
pour votre soutien
c'est important course à pied à présent
les organisateurs de la 43e édition du
paris versailles ont pris la décision de
reporter l la course initialement prévu
le 27 septembre au 26 septembre 2009 21
chaque année à 25 mille coureurs
prennent le départ de la compétition
depuis la tour eiffel pour rejoindre le
château de versailles dans le sprint
final
le paris versailles qui a également
perdu son président jean-marc fresnel
l'adjoint au maire délégué aux sports à
la ville de versailles décédées des
suites du coït 19 début mai ce passionné
d'athlétisme avait 71 ans ses
funérailles se sont déroulées le
mercredi 13 mai devant des membres du
conseil municipal
nos pensées vont à ses proches c'est la
fin de ce sept huit sports à bientôt sur
tv 78
[Musique]